[Música]
hoy en directo vamos a Buenos Aires
donde finalizó la séptima cumbre de la
celac un encuentro marcado por la
ausencia de la delegación venezolana que
argumentó un supuesto plan de agresiones
33 países asistieron a la cita de la que
salió un documento de 111 puntos y para
ampliar la información conectamos con
natalio cosoy corresponsal de France 24
en la capital Argentina natalio Cuáles
son los detalles más relevantes de la
declaración final
terminó esta cumbre de la celac en
Buenos Aires con el traspaso de la
presidencia pro tempore de Argentina a
San Vicente y Las Granadinas una de las
naciones más pequeñas de la región que
se encuentra en el Caribe los 33
representantes de los estados que
participaron en este encuentro y que
forman parte de la celac llegaron a un
consenso que se tradujo en una
declaración de Buenos Aires con 111
puntos en los que se insiste mucho en la
integración regional en el pedido de
financiamiento internacional
también se habló de la exigencia de que
se levante el bloqueo contra Cuba
también del respaldo a las negociaciones
entre el gobierno y la oposición en
Venezuela se defendió las instituciones
democráticas pero también la no
intervención en los asuntos de los
estados nacionales y a lo largo de la
Cumbre hubo bastante apoyo respaldo y
celebración por el regreso de Brasil a
este foro Y es que eran muchos los temas
a discutir en Qué materias no hubo
acuerdos
por supuesto no fueron todos consensos
hubo posiciones diferentes sobre Cómo
interpretar cuando un estado es
democrático no respeta las instituciones
hubo señalamientos por ejemplo a
Venezuela Cuba es el presidente de
Uruguay y la calle Pou dijo hay países
que no respetan los Derechos Humanos Más
allá de que la declaración no hace
menciones específicas de ningún tipo
también apareció permanentemente esta
discusión que hay dentro del mercosur
que está dentro vemos los países del
mercosur fue forman parte de la celac
esta discusión porque Uruguay está
negociando individualmente un acuerdo de
libre comercio con china esto genera
ciertas tensiones dentro del bloque va a
haber una reunión entre la calle Pou y
Lula da Silva el día miércoles veremos
si sale algo nuevo de esa reunión y algo
interesante que dijo en conferencia de
prensa el presidente de Colombia Petro
el hecho de que los foros regionales los
organismos regionales muchas veces
varían crecen o se achican y pierden o
ganan fuerza dependiendo de las
posiciones políticas y de los y los
contrapesos políticos hacia izquierda o
derecha en la región y Consideró que es
encontrar una forma de que se sostengan
Más allá de esas variaciones en los
gobiernos de América Latina